hier haben wir ein wort was du auch
schon in bezug auf mich benutzt hast
man ist sehr lästig und unanständig
dieses wort wurde erst kürzlich von
nicolas steiner hier in bezug auf kommt
[Musik]
wir widmen uns kommentaren und
reaktionen das hätten wir schon längst
mal machen sollen und wir danken euch
schon mal vorab für die kommentare weil
wir wissen nicht was kommt
deswegen macht es lieber jetzt
nervtötende steiner und tinga das ist
wie fortgeschrieben ist der pause pause
pause und tingler so würde ich das eher
verstehen ganz schlimmen ich erinnere
mich an ping las bücher besser erhielte
zwischendurch mal die luft an
ich sollte vielleicht zwischendurch mal
die luft anhalten
mach doch mal ich mach es gerade jetzt
in diesem moment und trotzdem kann nicht
sprechen
ihr zwei lasst mich regelmäßig in der
u-bahn verhaltensauffällig werden
ich sollte euch erst zu hause anschauen
nicht den kompletten werbung mit meinem
lachen bescheiden das ist noch mal
freilich eine anweisung wo man uns am
besten anschauen kann zu hause auf dem
wc
da geht es nicht um ein buch sondern um
eine selbstdarstellung von zwei personen
zusammen mit einem tv sender
ja so ist es mein herr das ist ja
schlimm diese guckt er uns denn dann
kulissen der innerlichkeit wow danke
philipp tingler was für ein nützlicher
und schöner ausdruck kulissen der
herrlichkeit also sehr gerne ich bemühe
mich immer darum in nützlichen und
schönen ausdrucken zu sprechen ja jetzt
kommt der nächste also vielleicht dann
eine antwort darauf
er macht sich nur lustig auf kosten von
der autoren braucht das anscheinend um
sich gut zu fühlen ich frage mich welche
minderwertigkeitskomplex damit
kompensiert wird unangenehm
ich mache mich gelegentlich lustig das
stimmt aber auch über mich selbst es
gibt leider noch andere autoren innen
über die sich philipp tingler manchmal
blockiert sitzt du auch noch nach oder
was ich habe jetzt mal hier dieses ding
übernommen weil es ist eigentlich besser
gelernt habe merke ich gerade könnte er
sie mal ausreden lassen okay also das
tue ich jetzt also das gute an uns
beiden ist dass wir uns ständig
gegenseitig ins wort fallen neruda nicht
erkannt
ich hätte meinen hintern auf sie
verwendet das war das ist weißt du noch
wie bei dem es auch so schön weil man
anhand dieser kommentare auch mit flash
hat sich ein paar kleine erinnert die
mir eigentlich ganz gut gefallen haben
um ehrlich zu sein ich kann mir dabei
haben die auch gut gefallen
sie war nur etwas erstaunt dass sich
offenbaren die ruder was ich schon
verdrängt habe nicht erkannte ja das
passiert den westen
ich liebe diese beiden einfach und wie
immer originell und sehr ehrlich das ist
aber auch ein schöner schluss kommentar
nachdem wir ja doch ein bisschen
einstecken musste hier oder also
geschützt
ich weiß nicht wie ihr jetzt die
aktuelle staffel gefunden habt
kommentiert doch einfach fleißig weiter
ihr könnt auch euren frust loswerden ihr
könnt eure liebe loswerden zu uns und
dann machen wir das bald wieder mal
gucken und ich danke euch dass ihr
überhaupt kommentiert habt